INSTRUCTOR: Hi
DATA-2100 students.
Go ahead and
navigate to your data
2100 while examples,
Google Colab, a link
that I have placed
up above this video.
And we'll go ahead and jump
into that in just a second.
But really quickly
I want to make sure
that we review
the variables math
and print in Python
as a reminder,
variables are a symbol or word
that represents some data value.
The print allows
us to see output
and then we can do all
mathematical operations,
you'll see over here that we're
very familiar with addition,
subtraction, multiplication,
division, exponent, remainder,
and floor division.
Now, remainder and
floor division,
you may not be as familiar with.
Remainder uses the percentage
sign, we call it a modulus
when we're using it
in this way in Python.
And floor division uses my
divide symbol, if you will.
But there's two of them.
So let's go back to
what the remainder does.
The remainder, as it
sounds, finds the remainder
of some mathematical operations.
So if I said 43 modulus 10.
So if I made it look like
this, 43 modulus 10, then
I would have right 43 divided by
10 is 4 with a remainder of 3.
So the answer to this equation
if you would be if you will,
would be 3, the
remainder of that.
Now, floor division
does just the opposite.
Floor division if
I said 43 again,
my two division signs,
my two slashes 10,
what this is going
to say is it's going
to chop off the remainder.
So 43 divided by 10 is
4 with a remainder of 3.
And this output would be 4.
We just chop off that remainder.
So again, remainder of
floor division are opposites
and we use them in Python.
But just so you're aware,
those are the two maybe ones
that you're not
as familiar with.
We can, of course,
ask for user input
that we've talked already about.
We can ask-- please enter
your favorite economist.
And inputs are always
considered strings to Python.
So if we need to transform
the inputs to be integers,
then we can harness
an integer function
and say transform or convert
this input to be an integer.
And then we can perform
mathematical operations on it.
So as an introduction
to a while loops,
a loop makes a set
of instructions
happen over and
over and over again.
Usually based on
meaning some condition.
So while some
condition is true, keep
executing these lines of code.
So while loops I want to
put a big caution here.
My advice as we
approach while loops
is that we get our base
code working, if you will.
The code we want to repeat
over and over again.
We get that working really well.
And then we add
in the while loop.
If not can be stuck in
this infinite loop of fun
where you're just-- and it
just keeps running and running
and running.
So we're going to avoid those.
While loops have
this basic format.
So we say while some
condition is true.
So that can be we can
say while true actually.
But we can say while
x is less than 10,
do the actions that are indented
and beneath the while loop.
You notice that,
we're indenting.
Python makes extensive
use of indentations.
Then within that while
loop, we do need something
that should modify the condition
above to actually allow
us to leave the while loop.
So that's something
that we'll do
is to break out of
that while loop.
So let's go ahead.
And as a reminder, your
Python workbook files
are linked through
the whole course.
Please look for those.
You'll notice them on the pages
that we're talking about Python.
So please scroll down and click
on those Python workbook files.
And you can work with
those workbook files
as an additional
resource for you.
So let's continue on here.
Here within my while
examples, you're
going to learn how to
create while loops in Python
by completing these examples.
This will not be submitted.
This is just our examples.
So I want to create a
program that asks the user
to guess my favorite candy bar.
We're going to keep asking
user to guess my favorite candy
bar until they get it right.
Count the number of guesses they
make and output it to the user.
So let's go ahead
and try this out.
So I'm going to
say, I first off I
need them to guess my
favorite candy bar.
So I need to actually declare
my favorite candy bar.
So I'll say favcandybar is
equal to let's say Snickers.
That actually sounds
super good right now.
So set it equal to your
favorite candy bar.
Then we're going to
keep asking the user
to guess my favorite candy bar.
So let's go ahead and say,
I need to then ask user for
or to guess my
favorite candy bar.
And we'll say userguess
equal to input.
Please guess my
favorite candy bar.
So once I asked my user for to
guess my favorite candy bar,
do I care if what they enter
is considered a string?
No, I want it to be
considered a string.
Because snickers is a
string type of data,
so when they input
their guess, it
should be considered
a string type of data.
So now what I want to do
is I want to say, while--
well, actually let's just keep
going with this for a minute
and then we'll add
in our while logic.
So user guess-- Oh I
have a lot of S's there.
We'll delete out that.
What I want to do
then is I want to keep
asking the user to
guess my favorite candy
bar until they get it right.
So let's determine if the user
guesses my favorite candy bar.
So I'll say if user guess is
equal equal to favcandybar.
Now reminder here, we
use a double equals sign
when we're doing conditional
statements, that double equals
sign says, are these
two equal to each other?
We can't just say user guess
equal to fav candy bar,
because then it
thinks that we're
trying to actually assign
user guess to the value
of my favorite candy bar.
So then we'll print
if that's true.
That is my favorite candy bar.
Good guess.
And then we're going
to at some point
say you guessed blank times.
We'll add in how many times they
guess here in just a little bit.
Then if that is
not true, if what
they guess-- so that if they
guess my favorite candy bar,
do this.
If that is not true,
my else needs to run,
then I print, nope, that is
not my favorite candy bar.
You have guessed blank times.
Try again.
So let's just run this
what we have right now.
So please guess my
favorite candy bar.
So if I say Snickers
and I hit Enter,
that is my favorite candy bar.
Good guess.
You guessed blank times.
Now, let's run this again.
And let's say, Butterfinger.
It says, Nope, that is
not my favorite candy bar.
You guessed blank times.
Try again.
Perfect.
So if they do not guess my
favorite candy bar, do this.
Perfect.
Now, what I want
to do, though, is
I want to have this
continue repeating,
but I want to try something out
really quick before we do that.
What if I say snickers
with a capital S.
So my fav candy bar is set
to snickers all lowercase.
If my user inputs capital S,
Snickers, and I hit Enter,
it says, Nope, that is
not my favorite candy bar.
I'll leave a little typo there.
So this remember, Python
is case sensitive.
So if I want to ensure
that whatever they enter
I don't want it to
be case sensitive,
then I can say make their
guess, not case sensitive.
And I'll say user guess equal
to user guess dot lower.
So I am taking the
user guesses variable.
The value of that variable
is whatever they enter.
And I'm lowercasing it
and assigning it back
to be the value of user guess.
So now, when I run this and
I say capital S Snickers
and I hit Enter, that is
my favorite candy bar.
Good guess.
You guessed blank times.
So now it's not case
sensitive, which is great.
Now, I want this to
keep asking my user
to guess my favorite candy
bar until they get it right.
So I want this program to happen
over and over and over again.
Now, I can do a
couple of things here.
What I'm going to do is I'm
going to actually declare.
We call this a marker variable.
I'll say correct
input equal to 0.
This is a marker variable.
What a marker variable
does is it basically
is the variable that we set the
condition for in my while loop.
So I'll say while correct
input is equal equal to 0.
And I like to put my
conditions within parentheses.
You don't have to.
But while correct input
is equal equal to 0.
So keep doing this
until we change
the value of correct input.
So while correct input
is equal equal to 0,
I want to continue asking
my user over and over again
to please guess my
favorite candy bar.
I want that process to happen
over and over and over again.
So keep asking them right.
If they don't get it
correct, keep asking them.
Then I still want to
lower their guess.
And then also I want
to say if user guess is
equal equal to a
candy bar, so we're
going to assess their guess
every time through here.
Now, at the point that I want
to break out of my while loop,
let's determine
what that point is.
So let's just play this
program here again.
So I'll say please guess
my favorite candy bar.
If I say snickers
and I hit Enter,
it says that is my
favorite candy bar.
Good guess.
You guessed blank times.
Then it says please
guess my candy bar again.
Well, I don't want that.
So we can come up here
and stop my program.
And I know that I want
to stop asking my user,
I want to exit the
while loop again,
everything indented and beneath
this while loop happens,
so long as correct
input is equal to 0.
So I want to exit my
while loop once they
guess my favorite candy bar.
So I'm going to say
correct input equal to 1.
We're just going to change
the marker variable's value
to leave while loop So now
when I run this, please guess
my favorite candy bar.
I say Snickers and I hit Enter.
It says that is my
favorite candy bar.
Good guess.
You guessed blank times.
So now, let's say that, I guess,
random ones, butterfinger.
That is not my
favorite candy bar.
You guessed blank times.
Try again.
It asks me again.
So it went through this program.
It said, correct input
is equal equal to 0.
When my program first starts.
Then it asked me to guess
my favorite candy bar.
Then it analyzes.
It goes through these
two, my if and my else.
And the else is
true in this case.
Because the if is not
true, Butterfinger
does not equal Snickers.
Then once the else runs,
then it comes back up
to right underneath
this while loop
and it says, while correct
input is equal equal to 0.
That is still true.
So then let's run all
this program again.
So right now this please
guess my favorite candy bar.
We are here at this part of
the program on my second time
through.
So now, let's say Kit Kat.
So now, again, it came down
here the if is still not true.
So the else block runs.
Then it comes back up here, is
correct input still equal to 0?
Yes, that's still true.
So let's ask the user again to
input my favorite candy bar.
Now, let's say Snickers.
And it comes back up.
So once it says please
guess my favorite candy bar
I just responded Snickers.
Then it comes down
here and it says,
if user guess is equal equal
to candy bar, that is true.
Then this print runs.
That is my favorite candy bar.
And then my correct input
value changes to one.
And then I can
leave my while loop
because it comes
back here up here
and it says, Oh correct input
is no longer equal to 0.
Leave the while loop.
Now, I need to return though
every time that my user guesses,
I want to count the
number of times.
So I'm going to
elicit a counter.
I'm going to say
counter is equal to 0.
This counter variable is going
to increase one time every time
through the loop.
So every time my user guesses
something right beneath it,
I'm going to increase my counter
and I'll say, counter plus
equals 1.
This is incrementing the
counter variable by one
and assigning it back to be
equal to that counter variable.
So we take whatever counter
is equal to, increase it by 1,
and set it back equal to
that counter variable.
So this time through the
first time through it
will be equal to 1 right.
So let's go ahead and run this.
So it says please guess
my favorite candy bar,
I say Butterfinger.
That is incorrect.
My else block will run.
It's going to loop
back up around.
And Oh it says you
guessed blank times.
So in order for that
to return to me,
I actually need to
go back into my print
and let's say here
that we actually
want to use f strings here
within my first print, here
within my if block.
And instead of saying
you guessed blank times,
I want to replace blank
with my curly braces
and place a value from the
variable counter right there.
Same thing down
beneath, we're going
to replace the value from the
variable counter within my print
statement in my else block.
Make sure you tell it you're
using the F strings throughout.
So let's go ahead
and try this again.
What is my favorite candy bar?
I say Butterfinger, I hit Enter.
Nope, that is not my
favorite candy bar.
You have guessed 1 times.
Try again.
Now, let's say kit kat.
Same thing, I've
guessed 2 times.
Let's say Almond Joy, hit
Enter, again, three times.
Now, I'll say Snickers
and it says, that is
my favorite candy bar.
Good guess.
You guessed four times.
So it's counting every
time through that loop.
It increases the counter by one.
Awesome.
Now, we're going to create a
password validation program.
And I know that's
a little vague.
So we'll just follow
along here with me.
This password
validation program is
going to be something that
you're very familiar with.
Because this happens
almost every time
you try and log in to anything.
There's some password
validation program
happening on the back end
that says incorrect password.
So we're going to write a
password validation program.
And first off what
we're going to say
is we're going to
declare a password.
So I'm going to say
that my password is
equal to Yellowstone.
And I'm going to be tricky here.
And instead of an
E I'll put a 3.
We notice that this we want
this to be case sensitive.
So we're going to
keep it that way.
Now, what I want to do
is I want to ask my user
right to enter your password.
So we're saying that my
user's password is Yellowstone
So we're acting like our user is
trying to log in to a website.
We know the website knows
there's a database somewhere
that has it tracked
that Yellowstone
is my user's password.
So let's say now, that we
want to actually ask my user
to enter their password.
So I'll say user input
is equal to input,
please enter your password.
So now, when I run
this, I'm going
to be asked to please
enter your password.
I say happy, I hit Enter.
My program just ends because
there's nothing else after it.
So now, what I want to do
is I actually want to say,
well, did the user enter
the correct password?
So I'll say if
and you guessed it
password is equal
equal to user input.
Or let's actually
change that up.
It doesn't matter.
But maybe it'll be a little
easier to understand.
If user input is
equal to password,
then they got the
password right.
So they guessed their
correct password.
For some people, passwords
can be a guessing game.
If it says incorrect
password, you're like, oh no.
So we're basically creating
that program to do that.
So if this is true, we're
going to print to them nice.
That is your password, perfect.
Now, if that is not
true I'll say else,
meaning they did not
guess their password.
And with this time, what
I want to say is print,
incorrect password, try again.
so let's run this and
see if this will work.
So please enter your password.
If I enter my actual
correct password
that I have established up here
and I hit Enter, it says nice.
That is your password.
Now, if I run it
again and I say happy,
the incorrect says incorrect
password, try again.
But we notice this isn't asking
me over and over and over again.
I have to keep running
the program every time.
So now, I want to
have it happen over
and over and over again until
they guess the correct password.
So I want to establish
password is Yellowstone
before I start my while loop.
And this time, I want
to say while true.
This means that run
this or continue.
Let's see.
Keep running everything
indented and beneath
until you hit the break command.
So now, what I want
to do is I want
to continue asking
my user over and over
and over again to
enter their password.
Then I want to
evaluate if they guess
their password, correct or not.
But I want to leave this while
loop once they have correctly
guessed their password.
So after I output to them print
a nice that is your password.
I want to validate to them
that they got it correctly.
Then I'm going to
break and we just
it's called the break command.
And it says leave that while
loop and I'll say break.
This is going to
leave the while loop.
Then what I want to once
they've left the while loop,
then I'm just going to
print end of program.
Meaning that they've
left the while loop,
and so they can continue on
and entering their username
for example.
So let's just go
ahead and run this.
Please enter your password.
I'm going to say happy.
I'll hit Enter,
incorrect password.
Try again.
Again, it asks me again.
So everything
indented beneath this.
You can see here this arrow
is saying we're asking you
please enter your password.
So it's saying please
enter your password again.
Let's say not happy.
I'll hit Enter,
and it goes through
and it says if the user input is
equal to password, print this.
This is not true.
So then my else block runs
my incorrect password.
Try again.
Prompt is output
to me as the user.
Then again, it comes back up.
It still hasn't hit
the break command.
So it's going to ask me again,
to please enter my password.
Now, let's enter in Yellowstone
now and I'll hit Enter.
And it just outputs to me.
Nice that is your
program, your password.
I leave the while loop,
and so the next part
of my program that is lined up
with my while loop can then run.
Because once I've left
that while loop, then
my Python program
says, what else
is in line with
that while loop now
that the user has successfully
exited that while loop.
So it will do everything now
and alongside that fully left
aligned part of my program which
says print end of my program.
Perfect.
Now, using a while
loop, we're going
to write a program that
prints out a countdown.
It starts by printing the value
of 10 and then it counts down.
When the value of the
countdown is equal to 0,
the program should print
the words blast off.
So we want to do something
that basically, we
need to establish first.
It starts by printing
the value of 10.
So let's just say that we have
established a starting value.
And I'm going to say
that x is equal to 10.
Now, I want to decrease
the value of 10.
So I'm to say x is equal to 10.
And then I want to count down.
So let me say x is
equal to 10 print x.
So let's run that.
Outputs 10 to me.
Now, let's say let's
decrease the value
of x, I'm going to say x minus
equals 10 or minus equals 1.
Now, print x.
Let's run this.
So we notice that we
have x is equal to 10.
Then we print x.
Then we do the same thing
we were just doing up
above with my counter we were
adding one and assigning it back
to be the value of x.
In this case, I'm decreasing
the value of x by 1
and then I'll print x.
Now, I don't want
to have to do this
over and over and over again.
So I'm going to actually
now use a while loop.
So let's say that we're going
to establish my starting value.
I know that I really want x to
be equal to 10 to begin with.
And let's say that
while x is greater
than 0, because I want blast
off to print when it hits 0.
I want to print x and then
decrease the value of x by 1.
So let's just run this
and see what happens.
10, 9, 8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Perfect.
So what it's doing is it's
saying our x is equal to 0.
So my while loop this
first condition is true.
Then I print 10.
Then I decrease the
value of x by 1.
Then I come back up to the
beginning of my while loop,
9 is now the value of x.
Because I decreased it by 1,
I say 9 is greater than 0.
So that I can print 9, and then
I can decrease that value again
by one.
Come back up again.
Now, x is equal to 8
and keep on doing that.
Now, at the very end here I
decrease the value of x one
last time after I print one.
So then x is equal to 0.
Comes back up here, it says
while x is greater than 0.
This is no longer true, so
it leaves my while loop.
So what I want to do is when
it leaves my while loop,
I'm also asked up above that
when the value of the countdown
is equal to 0, the program
should print the words
blast off.
Now, we can do this
a couple of ways,
but I'm going to say that while
x is greater than 0, do this.
And then I will say when
x is equal to 0, do this.
And I just want to print
x and then blast off.
So I'm going to print
the value of x and then
I'll say blast off.
So now when I run this, I notice
that I have 10, 9, 8, 7, 5--
I can't say that as
fast as I wanted to.
I'm counting down from 10 to 0.
Once that value is 0 and my--
it breaks out of my while loop,
it does not print zero again.
Then it comes back here again
to everything left aligned
and it says, what's the
next part of this program
once I leave this while loop?
The next part of this
program is my print statement
that says, now, print the
value of x, which is 0,
and then print blast off.
So there you have
these examples.
Again, save these in your--
make sure that you clicked
Copy to drive all of that
and that you are saving these
so that you can use them
as a good resource as we go
throughout our Python module.
Thanks, everybody.
Take care.